THE JANUARY THIRTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY HEARING OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND IT WITH
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM ARE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND THEN VOTE ON
BILLS WHEN WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
BILLS IN SIGNED IN ORDER AND
THEN WE WILL HAVE ONE BILL
THAT'S PROPOSED PROPOSED
CONSENT AB TEN SEVENTY ONE. OUR
FIRST UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON WITH A. B. NINETEEN.
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OUR FIRST OFF I
JUST WANT TO START OFF I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. AB
NINETEEN AS IN PRINT WITH
ESTABLISH A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP-COUNTY ROAD MAINTENANCE
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS. PURCHASE
VEGETATION ANAGEMENT EQUIPMENT
TO PREVENT WILDFIRES ALONG
COUNTY MAINTAIN STREETS AND
ROADS ITH IN HIGH AND VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
SONGS. ACCORDING TO THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO NEARLY 25% OF
WILDFIRES. IN THE COUNTY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WERE VEHICLE RELATED
FIRES. THE MOST NOTABLE VEHICLE
RELATED FIRE THE CAR FIRE BURN
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES DESTROYED MORE THAN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND
KILLED AT LEAST SEVEN PEOPLE.
VEHICLE FIRES CAN BE CAUSED BY
AN ENGINE CATCHING FIRE BECAUSE
IT'S PULLING MAINTAIN A FAILING
CATALYTIC CONVERTER A FLAT TIRE
OR SOMEONE DRAGGING A METAL
CHAIN OR EVEN PULLING OVER JUST
SIMPLY TO PULL OVER TO MAKE A
PHONE CALL IN A BRUSHY AREA ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD. AND
IGNITING DRY GRASS BY FOCUSING
ON THE FOOT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
ALONG COUNTY MAINTAIN ROADWAYS
AB NINETEEN IS INTENDED TO HELP
PREVENT NEARLY ONE QUARTER OF
ALL WILDFIRES. THIS GRANT IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT TO LOCAL WORLD
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO MANAGE VEGETATION
ALONG COUNTY STREETS AND ROADS.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I'M
ACCEPTING TODAY WILL
APPROPRIATE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
FIRE PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM.
AND REQUIRE THOSE FUNDS TO BE
FOCUS OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
EQUIPMENT AND FUEL REDUCTION
ALONG ROADWAYS I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S DESIRE TO NOT
CREATE DUPLICATIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING. TOWARD ENSURING THAT
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED IN THIS
BILL OR DISPENSED IN A TARGETED
MANNER TO THE COMMUNITIES WITH
THE GREATEST NEED- THIS BILL-
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM MANY MANY
FIRE DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FIRE TO SIX
ASSOCIATION CAL FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION- AND THE LIST GOES
ON AND ON- I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
FIRE CHIEF STEVEN AB FROM THE
NORTH COUNTY FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT. AT AND STACY HEATON
FROM RC RC AS WITNESSES TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY WITNESS
WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS STEVE ABBOTT
PARK CHIEF MECHANIC FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT SO VERY
BRIEFLY- IN MY THIRTY YEAR
TENURE NOW WITH OUR COUNTY FIRE
WE'VE EXPERIENCED THREE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES THAT'S THREE
TOO MANY THANKFULLY UNLIKE SOME
OF THE OTHER- FIRES THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
MENTIONED- WE DID NOT HAVE. ANY
FATALITIES. HOWEVER AT ROADSIDE
CLEARANCE IN ADDITION TO ALL
THE FACTORS THAT SHE MENTIONED
ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES
THE- PROBABILITY OF SURVIVING
ESCAPING A WILDFIRE AYE TAKING
FOR EXAMPLE THE CEDAR FIRE THAT
HAPPENED IN TWO THOUSAND THREE-
ONE OF THE STATE'S DEADLIEST
FIRES AT THIRTEEN FATALE THESE
VIRTUALLY ALL THOSE BRUTALITIES
WERE A RESULT OF- DE. DEATH
ALONG THE ROADWAYS WHAT WHILE
ATTEMPTING TO FLEE THE FIRE. I
THINK ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
COULD BE THOUGHT IS- YOU KNOW
WHAT ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY OF A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THIS- AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
SEVEN WERE BUYING. EQUIPMENT
AND NOT AS WE'RE NOT
PREDOMINATELY FUNDING SERVICES
WITH THIS AND SO THAT'S GIVING
THE FIRE AGENCIES IN THE
COUNTY. I ROAD APARTMENTS IS
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO GET
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS UP AND
RUNNING. TO USE OR CASE IN
POINT- ARE VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE 90% OF OUR
DISTRICT A STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA. IT TOOK A COUNTY ROAD
DEPARTMENT UNTIL- THE MONTH OF
OCTOBER WHICH IS ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS TOO LATE TO CLEAR THE
ROADS WITHIN OUR- WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION. AND THAT'S
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
IN TALKING WITH THE ROAD
SUPERVISOR THEY INDICATED- YOU
KNOW- CHIEF IT. IF WE COULD
RENT THE EQUIPMENT WE WOULD
RENT IT SO WE CAN GET THIS WORK
DONE BUT THERE IS SIMPLY NOT
AND TO BE HAPPY. AND THAT TO ME
WAS THE LIGHT BULBS THAT TO A
BOY WE REALLY NEED A PROGRAM.
LIKE THIS AND ALONG COMES.
SENATE MEMBER WALDRON FOR THIS
IS A WONDERFUL. OKAY REQUEST.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M STACY HEAT
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE AT SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND YOU KNOW THE CAR FIRE
WAS ACTUALLY IN ONE OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTY SHASTA COUNTY AND
IT PRETTY WELL DESTROYED THE
CITY READING AS YOU WELL KNOW.
AND IN MANY OF OUR COUNTIES
HAVE A LOT OF COMMUNITIES THAT
COULD USE THIS TYPE OF A
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN PURCHASE
EQUIPMENT TO GO OUT AND DO
CLEARANCES AROUND THE ROADS TO
PREVENT SUCH FIRES LIKE THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF AREAS OF YOU
KNOW- SOCIAL ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT COULD REALLY
USE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS TELL
PURCHASE EQUIPMENT TO
MAINTAINING TO KEEP THAT
SUSTAINABLE AS CHIEF ABBOTT
SAID. AND THIS PROGRAM COULD BE
OF GREAT USE AMONG A LOT OF OR
MEMBER COUNTIES AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY
WE THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING UP BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU OR TO ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
JUST NAME AND- WHO YOU'RE WITH.
CHRIS RESERVE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
NIGGLING ATLANTIS'S SENEGAL GAS
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. IS SIGNAL TO GET
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY I SEE NONE I'M
HAPPY TO SEE YOU. MR FOR WOULD
YOU DO HAVE A LATE HAND
ACTUALLY I WAS THE PRICE THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO SAYING I KNOW
I KNOW I USUALLY TRY NOT TO
SPEAK MUCH BUT ON THIS WHEN SHE
DIED AND SOMEOF THEM ARE-
COMING FROM THE FIRE SERVICE.
THERE'S VERY FEW THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DEVASTATION OF WILDFIRES IN
DEALING WITH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. IT'S KIND OF IT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THIS AND IT'S
STARTING TO GROW THE- SOME
STEAM BEHIND IT AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY. WHAT WE CAN DO
TO TAKE THE INTENSITY OF THESE
FIRES THAT OUR MEN AND WOMEN
THAT THEY ARE CALLED TO GO
FIGHT THEM GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CATCH THESE
THINGS BEFORE THEY GROW UP YOU
KNOW WHERE IT DOESN'T MATTER
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE THROW OUT
UNTIL THE WEATHER COOPERATES
AND SOME THINGS LIKE THAT. IT'S
GOING TO GET OUT OF CONTROL SO
I APPRECIATE YOU SOMEONE NUMBER
BRING US FORWARD- LOOK FOR TO
MOVING FORWARD. AND THE- LOVE
THE SPORT. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
THINK WE ARE HOPEFULLY MOVING
INTO AN ERA. IN THE- ERA OF-
RISK REDUCTION AND PREVENTION.
AS WE SEE WHAT WE'RE UP
AGAINST- WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
EVERYTHING ELSE SO. I THINK
THAT THIS WOULD BE MONEY WELL
SPENT- I WISH YOU THE BEST OF
LUCK WITH THAT IS MOST OF THE
PROCESS. I'M WITHOUT CAN WE
HAVE A VOTE. WE OWE TO INFORM
YET WE HAVE A QUORUM IS HIS WE
ESTABLISH A FARM. WILL TAKE A
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. I DIDN'T ASK YOU TO CLOSE
BUT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
UP WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY OUR
NEXT WE HAVE A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE MR LIVING. YOUR PEN
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR EXCELLENT SUGGESTION
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FROM LAST YEAR
BE AMENDED INTO AB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE AND THAT THE LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL BE
DELETED I WOULD WITH THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT LIKE TO
ACCEPT THAT STOP SUGGESTION. AS
A COMMITTEE AMEND. I AB
FOURTEEN FORTY WOULD HAVE
UPDATED LAWS INITIALLY THAT AND
ACTED IN THE NINETEEN THIRTIES
AND YOU MAY THIS MAY SOUND
FAMILIAR TO YOU SINCE YOU'VE
SEEN THIS BEFORE. I GOVERNOR
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
CALIFORNIA ENSURE THAT THE
STATE CAN GIVE PRIMARY
CONSIDERATION TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHEN MAKING OIL EXTRACTION
PERMITTING DECISIONS THE
GOVERNOR UNFORTUNATELY VETOED
THE BILL. HE HE THOUGHT HIS
STAFF PROBABLY ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THIS IT DIDN'T GO FAR ENOUGH-
COMPARED TO A DIFFERENT BILL
BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT- AFTER
THE BILL WAS VETOED AND ARE DO
YOU SEE A CO SPONSOR OF AB
FOURTEEN FORTY NOTED. THAT BOTH
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY WORKED IN
CONCERT. AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FORTY WOULD HAVE BOLSTERED THE
STATE'S LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
CONSIDER PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY
AND NATURAL RESOURCES. OUT
FIRST IN REGULATING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS
ANY CONCERNS WITH ME TODAY. IS
BILL OUT YOU HAD WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
OKAY BEFORE YOUR WITNESS AYE
TESTIFIES WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT TWO THOUSAND FORM
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLORA. FLOOR HERE CHAU.
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GARCIA.
GARCIA HERE LIMON. LIMON HERE
MATHIS. MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ ROUTE THIRTY STONE
STONE HERE. THANK YOU I'M HERE
WITH THIS PLACE YES I AM BILL
ALLEY A WITH ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT- THIS
IS PART OF A NOW ABOUT NINE
YEAR PROCESS OF REFORM AT
DOGGER FORMALLY DOCTOR NOW JAB
THE GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY OR DIVISION- AND THESE
ARE IMPORTANT SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGES ABOUT LOOKING
AT THEIR MISSION STATEMENT AND
CLEARLY THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING A STRONG PATH ON THIS
MISSION- TO BOTH LOOK AT
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES THAT
WILLING GAS DEVELOPMENT AND
EXPLORATION AFFECTS. AS WELL AS
HOW THE AGENCY OPERATES SO AB
TEN FIFTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MOANS BILL WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
LAST YEAR WE STILL THINK
THERE'S WORK TO DONE TO BE DONE
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES-
OF COOPERATION IN GETTING A
BILL FOR THAT WILL STILL FILL
IN SOME OF THESE GAPS ON
CHANGING THE MISSION AND
COMPLETING REFORM WE'RE GETTING
CLOSER OF TRUE REFORM OF GEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I SEE NINE
ANYBODY WITNESSING- INTERESTED
IN TESTIFY AGAINST A BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD. FOR THE
WORLD. TERM MEMBERS WE CENTERS
WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE HAD A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION TO THE
BILLING CURRENT PRINT BUT HAS
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WILL
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE DIALOGUE
WITH HIM AND HIS STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS TO SEE HOW THEY PLAN
ON WORKING ON ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE VETO MESSAGE BUT ALSO
HOW IT GOES IN CONCERT WITH-
MISLIM OWNS A BE TEN FIFTY
SEVEN SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION WITH
CONCERNS. SIGNAL WILL MOVE TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND A MISTER WOULD BE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OUR STUFF WE
OFFER AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WITHOUT ALL HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS QUEEN ROLL CALL
PLEASE. ITEM FIVE A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY MEMBER
LEVINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA FLORA NO CHAU.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA
ISLA MON LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MELENDEZ
ROUTE TO TREAT. STONE STONE I.
FIVE TWO THANK YOU WILL CALL
THE ROLL OPEN FOR I THINK YOU
ALSO MUCH THANK YOU WE MOVE NOW
TO AB FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
WELCOME. WILL THAT WILL NOT A
SECOND. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL MAKE THIS QUICK. FIRST I
WANT TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS AND AS YOU
KNOW AND MAYBE FIFTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN REQUIRES A STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO RECOMMEND A
COORDINATED STRATEGY REDUCING
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATE WITH
FORESTRY AGRICULTURE AND URBAN
ORGAN OR ORGANIC WASTE WITHOUT
SINCE WE'VE DONE MOTION I'LL
PASS IT ON TO MY- PEOPLE
TESTIFYING TODAY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY BOYD WITH A
CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON FUEL AND
ENERGY COALITION IN SUPPORT- WE%
THINK THAT THE STRATEGIC PLAN
IS NECESSARY TO BRING ALL OF
THE AGENCIES AND POLICIES
TOGETHER ONE ONE WERE TO A
DETERMINE WHAT ARE THE BEST
OUTCOMES FOR AGAIN NEXT VERSION
THANK YOU THANK YOU PURSUE YOUR
FIRST. TASK THAT TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. YES TEXT THANKS I'LL
TRY TO FOLLOW I'M BONNIE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE I
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE THERE WE'VE PASS A
SERIES OF- OF. OUR UNIQUE WAY
SCHOOLS OVER HE PAST TEN
YEARS- BUT THERE'S- YOU KNOW A
LOT OF CREATION LEFT TO BE DONE
SO FOR EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW WE
SELL OPENING BURNING OF CALL
CROP RESIDUE. I WHICH CREATES
AIR POLLUTION AND INEFFICIENT
USE OF JERRY MINARET MANURE AT
THE SAME TIME WHICH CREATES
WATER POLLUTION- BUT IF THESE
TWO EXTREMES ARE BETTER
COORDINATED THIS CAN RESULT IN
COMPOST WHICH WOULD. NOT ONLY
LEAD TO HEALTHY SOILS AND WATER
RETENTION BUT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION- TO THESE
POTENTIAL TYPES OF CO BENEFITS
ARE- WHAT WE'RE SEEKING. IN
THIS COURT A STRATEGY ANALYTICS
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN THIS. NEXT
WITNESS MADAM CHAIR JUST ALONG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COLLECTION AGAIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE DID SUPPORT THE
PREVIOUS VERSIONS. JUST TO MAKE
TWO POINTS HERE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL NO ONE'S TRYING TO
SECOND GUESS WHICH IS THE BEST
WAY OF DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
TO ME THAT MANDATES AND
SECONDLY WE NEED A HIGH LEVEL
EIGHT CROSS AGENCY. WE CON JUST
DEAL WITH CARRY CYCLE CDFA IT
HAS TO BE AT THAT LEVEL OF PR
SAY HANDS ARE BRINGING IT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO. COVER
ALL THE AGENCIES INVOLVED WE
URGE STRONGLY URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR IN THE NAME ONLY NUMBER
HALF THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR MEMBERS ARE CHAIR. AND
JOSIAH YOUNG ABOUT FOR THE BIO
ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK FENCED
MAKE ON BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE. OKAY ANYBODY
WISHING TO VOICE ANY OPPOSITION
OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE ITCHING TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST LEAVES
THE THIS IS A GREAT BILL I'D
LIKE TO- JOINT AUTHORED THIS
WITH YOU SHOW SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD IF
YOU'LL HAVE ME. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS THE SECOND. THAT
JUST ALSO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS WE ALL
KNOW. OPEN BIRDS ARE NOT THE
WAY TO REDUCE OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
ALL OPTIONS ON THE TABLE IN
ORDER TO. CREATIVELY SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS THANK YOU. ME KNOWS.
OKAY MS ARE YOUR CAR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A STRATEGIC PLAN
ON ORGANIC WASTE MANAGER WILL
PROVIDE LONG TERM TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AND DATA IN- INFORM
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
SUPPORT INCENTIVIZE THE
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF ORGANIC
WASTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU WITH A
CLEAVER ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM
SEVEN A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
BY IGOR CURRY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA
I LOW MOAN. THE MOAN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI STONE
STONE I. I THINK THEY WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OF THE PROCESS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
NOT SEEING ANY OTHER AUTHORS SO
IF ANYBODY ELSE IS- HAS A BILL
IN FRONT OF NATURAL RESOURCES
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LET'S GO BACK
NOW AND TAKE MISS WALDRON
SPILLED TAKE A VOTE ON THAT.
THIS WILL GROW. YEAH OKAY ROLL
CALL PLEASE. ITEM ONE A. B.
NINETEEN BY MEMBER WALDRON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA FLORA AYE
CHAU EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE LOW MOAN. Là
MON I MATHIS. MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ FIVE
MURATSUCHI STONE. SO NINE EIGHT
ZERO. EIGHT ZERO TIMES I BEG
YOUR PARDON WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR- MISTER SCEA WITH AB OR
FOUR SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FOR SIXTY
FOUR SAYS THE VICE THAT THE
CONTRIBUTION OF NATURAL SOURCES
OF AIR POLLUTION INCLUDED IN
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AIR
POLLUTION INVENTORY MUST
INCLUDE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
WE KNOW THAT WHILE PRICE FOR
THIS A RANGE OF HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTANTS FROM KNOWN CANCER
CAUSING SUBSTANCES TO TINY
PARTICLES THAT CAN AGGRAVATE
EXISTING HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
INCREASED SERVICE OF HEART
ATTACK OR STROKE WELL IT
APPEARS THAT THE AIR BE ALREADY
INCLUDES EMISSIONS FROM
WILDFIRES IN ITS INVENTORY OF
NATURAL SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION THE MOSTLY THINK
CALIFORNIA ALMANAC OF EMISSIONS
AND OUR QUALITY ONLY INCLUDE
WELL FIRE EMISSIONS ESTIMATED.
BASED ON WELFARE ACTIVITY FROM
200-012-2000 TEN. THERE IS A
NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR MORE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES ARE IN
RECENT YEARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. HANK YOU YOU
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON STACY HEAT RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL FOR AT. QUANTIFYING THE
REAL EMISSIONS FROM.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
SOMEWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS KELLY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
IS FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEEING NONE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
MATHIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
GREAT BILL I'D LOVE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU. OKAY LEADING
UP THINKING BACK. AT THE
SLIGHTEST. THANK YOU- DID THEY
SAY WHY THEY ONLY HAVE FROM TWO
THOUSAND ONE OR TWO THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND TEN FACTORED INTO
THEIR REPORT. NO I MEAN I THINK
BEFORE WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT
DATA THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE AND
THERE WAS NOT TOO MUCH OF A
SHIP BUT WE SEEM. EACH YEAR A
CITY NEW RECORDS AND NEW
PATTERNS AND SO. I THINK IT'S
BABY AT A PRACTICE THAT MIGHT
HAVE MADE SENSE IN THE PAST.
INTERESTING OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PASSING A WHAT ELSE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. ITEM TWO
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR BY
CRISTINA GARCIA MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA. FLOOR I CHAU. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE LOW MOAN. Là MON I MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ I WROTE
TO TREAT STONE. SO NINE NINE
ZERO NINE TWO ZERO THE BILL
PASSES OUT MR MCCARTY WOULD YOU
LIKE 2% HERBAL THANK YOU. THE
MOVIE. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON FIFTEEN NO SIX. AS
IT. WILL ONLY TAKE MY FOLDER
OUT. SO THIS IS A CLEAN UP BILL
FROM MARK GREEN RESTAURANTS-RECYCLING BILL A LAST YEAR
FOCUSING ON THE AMUSEMENT PARK
INDUSTRY A TECHNICAL CLEANUP WE
AGREED TO TAKE THAT'S THE
BILL'S GOING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT
THIS MORNING THANK YOU THANK
YOU YOU HAVE A WITNESS WHO WANT
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AARON GUERRERO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME
PARKS ASSOCIATION FOR STUFF I
WANT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR
CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
WILL BE VERY BRIEF I KNOW
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO IT
THIS IS A- VERY IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION THAT WE NEED- AND
IT WOULD APPLY AB TWENTY SEVEN
FROM LAST YEAR ONLY TO THE- THE
RESTAURANTS AND THEME PARKS AND
NOT THROUGHOUT THE THEME PARK-
ANYBODY HAS BEEN TO A THEME
PARK KNOWS THAT THERE ARE.
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF. PLANO
TRASH CANS THROUGHOUT THE PARK
NOT NEAR EATING AREAS. THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION
AND WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITION
OF THE URGENCY CLASSES WELL
IT'S CRITICAL. THAT THIS BILL
GOING TO PLACE BEFORE AB EIGHT
TWENTY SEVENTH EFFECTIVE DATE
OF JULY FIRST. SO THANK YOU I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. HI THIS
IS BONNIE WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE- WE ARE SPONSORED
THIS BILL LAST YEAR THE ARMS
LIMóN MCCARTY AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE AUTHOR. TO
ENSURE THAT IT KEEPS IN LINE
WITH ITS ORIGINAL INTENT. SIX
THANK YOU AND TO CLARIFY MR
MCCARTY THERE WERE SOME
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WILL YOU
BE ACCEPTING YES. WE WILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. OKAY
CINEMA TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I SEE NINETY TO A
MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST THAT THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US AND EXPLAIN
MANNER AND ASK YOUR AT THE-
THANK YOU CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. ITEM SIX A. B.
FIFTEEN OH SIX BY MCCARTY TE
MOTION IS THAT THE URGENCY BE
ADOPTED AMEND AND DO PASS.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLOOR I'D CHAU. CHAU
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GARCIA
GARCIA ISLA MON. THE MOAN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI. STONE STONE I
TEN ZERO TENSER THAT BILL IS
OUT WHILE WE WAIT FOR A FINAL
AUTHOR LET'S I TAKE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TO PASS ITS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ITEM
THREE EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SIX
BONTA MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. NOT
ENOUGH ON TO THIS IS I'M SORRY
ONE. I GOT THE WRONG ONE IN
FRONT OF ME. DO OVER. ITEM FOUR
AB TEN SEVENTY ONE BY MEMBER
LIMóN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS WITH
CONSENT RECOMMENDATION MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I LOW
MOAN. THE MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY. RT I
MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MURATSUCHI JOHN SO NINE TEN
ZERO. HONESTLY LIKE. YEAH WE'RE
GONNA WHILE WE WAIT FOR A FINAL
AUTHOR WE'RE GOING TO ACCEPT
ADD ONS TO OKAY NEVER MIND WE
HAVE OUR WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR.
GREAT WELCOME MR BONTA. YOU'RE
HERE FOR EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES AND STAFF
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB NINE SIXTY SIX I
WANNA. FIRST SAY I AM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THAT- I'M PLEASED TO
BUY THAT AB NINE SIX SIX SIX
WHICH- WILL TAKE S. STEPS TO.
MEASURE AND REDUCE THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT CALIFORNIA CEMENT AND
CONCRETE INDUSTRIES CEMENT. AND
ITS RELATED PRODUCT CONCRETE
ARE VITAL TO OUR CIVILIZATION
AND USED IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT. BUT
CEMENT PRODUCTION IS ALSO ONE
OF THE MOST ENERGY. AND CARBON
INTENSIVE MANUFACTURING PROCESS
SEES. IN THE WORLD ON ITS OWN
THE GLOBAL CEMENT INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTS FOR BETWEEN FIVE AND
EIGHT PERCENT. OF THE WORLD'S
HARMFUL CARBON EMISSIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT CEMENT MAN
FACTORIES PRIMARILY USE COAL
AND PETROLEUM COKE AS FUEL FOR
THE COURT FOR THEIR OPERATIONS
AND- CALIFORNIA'S CEMENT
COMPANIES ARE THE LARGEST
CONSUMERS OF COAL IN THE STATE.
THANKS TO ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRODUCTION
PROCESS SEES. THE CLEANEST
CEMENT FACTORIES CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY CUT POLLUTION AB
NINE SIX SIX REQUIRE CEMENT
MANUFACTURERS TO MEASURE AND
REPORT. THEIR EMISSIONS USING
THIRD PARTY VERIFIED DOCUMENTS
CALLED ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCT
DECLARATIONS OR EP'S FOR SHORT.
AND I BELIEVE IN THE NINE SIX
SIX IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
IDENTIFY WAYS TO ADDRESS. OUR
EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE AS A GLOBAL
LEADER ON CLIMATE ACTION
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEADING-
AND THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE AB NINE SIXTY SIX. I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE WITH ME.
FIVE ONE IS HERE WITH ME CHRIS
ERICKSON CEO OF BP SOFTWARE
COMPANY CLIMATE. TRAFFIC AND
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES THANK
YOU. I WANT TO START BY SAYING
MY COMPANY HAS BEEN GENERATED
DVDS- SINCE THEY WERE FIRST
INTRODUCED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND OUR CUSTOMERS HAVE NO
GENERATED OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
A PIECE IN THE MARKETPLACE-
WHICH IN A SEA CHANGE IN THE
ATTITUDE ABOUT HE PT'S IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS. IN PARTICULAR-
THEY WERE INITIALLY VIEWED AS
SORT OF A GREEN TAX- BY THE
INDUSTRY BUT MORE AND MORE
THEY'RE BEING ACCEPTED NOW AS
AN IMPORTANT NEW METRIC FOR THE
GROWING. LOW CARBON
CONSTRUCTION MARKET. AND I
THINK THAT'S NOT ONLY BECAUSE
OF THE DEMAND BUT THE RULES
HAVE CHANGED AND DEVELOPED THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE EIGHTY P.
THESE ARE VERY VERY COMPARISON
BETWEEN TEXAS. AND SECONDLY-
EPT AUTOMATION IS DRIVING THE
COST WAY WAY DOWN. ALL WITH
RESPECT TO THE CEMENT INDUSTRY
THEY'RE ALSO SEEING THIS CHANGE
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE THE
MAJOR PROVIDERS TO THE READY
MIX COMPANIES AND MOST OF THEM
ARE VERTICALLY INTEGRATED- IN
THE PAST THEY'VE BEEN USING
INDUSTRY AVERAGE GPD DATA. TO
SUPPORT THERE'S CONCRETE
PROVIDERS AND- THEY ARE NOW
PENALIZED- BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
PRODUCE AN UNCERTAINTY METRIC
OF PLUS OR MINUS 50% UP 250%
WHEN THEY USE THIS INDUSTRY
AVERAGE EPT- SO THAT THERE ARE
NOW MOTIVATED TO MOVE TOWARDS
FACILITY. SPECIFICALLY PRODUCE.
AND LAST OF ALL THEY'RE ALSO
MOTIVATED AT A MACRO LEVEL. THE
LARGEST CEMENT PRODUCER IN THE
WORLD WHICH IS HEIDELBERG
CEMENT. HAS COMMITTED TO REDUCE
OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT BY 30% BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND TO BE FULLY
CARBON NEUTRAL. ARE BY TWENTY
FIFTY SO OVERALL I SEE THIS
BILL AND MY COMPANY SEES THIS
BILL WAS VERY MUCH IN LINE WITH
MARKET TRENDS AND THE TIMING IS
JUST RIGHT. THANK YOU YOU KNOW
THE WITNESS I DO I ALSO HAVE
KEVIN PHILLIPS DIRECTOR OF THIS
YEAR CLUB CALIFORNIA. HI THANK
YOU- AND HAPPY NEW YEAR- WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
WE HAVE FOUND IN THE PAST ON OF
THEIR AND A VARIETY OF ISSUES
THAT DISCLOSURE IS ONE OF THE-
POWERFUL TOOLS THAT WE CAN USE
TO ENCOURAGE- NOT JUST
COMPANIES TO CLEAN UP THEIR ACT
BUT ALSO TO ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS
TO. PURCHASE THOSE THINGS THAT
ARE MOST BENEFICIAL AND THAT
WILL REDUCE- IMPACTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT THIS GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY THIS BILL WILL GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE- STATE
AGENCIES TO SEE WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE FROM
PURCHASING THESE PRODUCTS FROM
DIFFERENT VENDORS. AND AGAIN IT
WILL CERTAINLY SET UP A-
COMPETITIVE VERGE BY THE
VENDORS TO- REDUCE THEIR-
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
OTHER POLLUTANTS. THINGS WERE
STRONG SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. CHARLIE
READ WITH A CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION AND A BIG
PART OF OUR MEMBERSHIP ARE
CONCRETE PRODUCERS AND REALLY
AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
HAVE SUBMITTED A LETTER
EXPLAINING SOME ISSUES- HOPE
THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S OKAY TO
MAYBE TAKE A FEW SECONDS TO.
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE SURE JUSTIN
JUST KIND OF GENERAL BACKGROUND
IS PROBABLY A HUNDRED CONCRETE
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED PLANTS- DISPERSED
FROM THE STATE AND ALL THE
EFFORTS OF DEFINITELY BEGUN ARE
SOME COMPANIES ALREADY HAVE YOU
PT'S FOR ALL A PART OF THEIR
PRODUCTION OTHERS ARE ARE
PRODUCING THEM BUT THERE'S
STILL A LOT OUT THERE THAT THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE A- SORE CAN-
ISSUES THAT WE WERE HOPING THAT
CAN. BE ADDRESSED WE'VE HAD
SOME INITIAL CONVERSATIONS OF
THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE COMMITTEE
IN THE HOUSE TOO BUT IT'S
QUICKLY I THINK WANTED RECENT
TIME FOR IMPLEMENTATION- TO CAN
ADDRESS THE THRESHOLD. BILL I
FIFTY YARDS OF CONCRETE THINK
THAT MAYBE THE HIGHER. ALSO A
THRESHOLD. SIZE OF PLANT THAT
WOULD BE APPLICABLES TO- BEGIN
FOR THE MORE RURAL SMALLER LOW
VOLUME PLANTS LAW HARDER TO- DO
ALL THIS. IN SORT THE COST- AND
THIRD JUST- MAYBE SOMETHING
THAT SOME SORT OF GUARANTEE
THAT THE P. D. WOULD HAVE A-
CERTAIN LIFE TO IT I. WE ASK
FOR THAT BECAUSE THERE'S ALL
THESE OTHER BACKGROUND
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE PRODUCED
NATIONALLY WE DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER. THEY ONLY LAST
FOR FIVE YEARS SO DEPENDING ON
WHEN YOU PRODUCE THREE P. D.
YOU KNOW YOU MAY HAVE TO
PRODUCE ANOTHER ONE. A YEAR
LATER OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND THEN. ANOTHER WAY TO DRESS
AT TWO IS ALSO PER. PER PROJECT
AND YOU SOMETIMES A CALTRANS
PROJECT FIRST THIS CAN GO ON
FOR MORE THAN FIVE YEARS OR SO.
THOSE ARE COMMENTS A DEAF.
SHADE ALL THAT SESSION AND LOOK
FORD MORTON FIFTY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ARE OPPOSITION. OKAY YES GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TOM SEATS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE OVER
THE PAST YEAR REGARDING THIS
BILL AND- ESSENTIALLY WANT TO
EXPRESS THE FACT THAT ARE RE
INDUSTRY IS NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL. OUR ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCT
DECORATIONS IN THEMSELVES ARE
USEFUL FOR CAPTURING
INFORMATION MUCH OF WHICH WE
ALREADY SHARE WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WHO WE
COLLABORATE WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS REGARDING EMISSIONS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S CEMENT PRODUCERS
BUT WE WOULD URGE OF THIS BILL
TO INCLUDE SOME THINGS THAT
COULD HELP US MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THE SEARCH IS MEASURING
EMISSIONS THINGS LIKE AYE
INCENTIVIZING THE STATE TO USE
PORTLAND LIMESTONE CEMENT AND
BE ABOUT A 10% REDUCTION. WHICH
IS ALREADY BEING USED IN IN
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD FOR AS MANY
AS FORTY YEARSALSO ON THE USE
OF ALTERNATIVE FUELS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY- RESTRICTED IN OUR
STATE USED ELSEWHERE THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HELPING US REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE OF THAT OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCT
DECLARATIONS WILL AT SOME
POINT. SHOW THE IMPACT REMAIN
ABLE TO MAKE WITH THOSE
CHANGES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH G.
BODY ELSE. OKAY WITHOUT WILL GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY KIND. AND ONE DOES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO
MISTER BONTA REGARDING THE
REQUEST OF THE FIRST- WITNESS
WHO CAME TO SPEAK AND- WHEN NOT
IN OPPOSITION HE WAS NEUTRAL-
IS THERE ANY. ANYTHING DOWN THE
ROAD WHERE YOU ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS- THERE'S CONCERNS A
REQUEST THAT HE'D MADE. YES.
REALLY BUT THIS MINISTRY IN THE
CONCRETE INDUSTRY FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION ON THERE GATE
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD
MEETINGS WITH MATTER THE
DISTRICT WE'VE HAD SOME
MEETINGS UP HERE. AND I
CONTINUE TO APPRECIATE THE-
SOLUTION ORIENTED APPROACH THAT
THEY HAVE- THE LETTER- PREDATES
THE AMENDMENTS. THE MANAGER
JUST TAKEN PRETTY MUCH THIS
MORNING SO MISTER A MAY NOT BE
AWARE OF ALL OF THEM ONE OF THE
THINGS ON HIS LIST WE CAN CROSS
OFF BECAUSE WE'VE ADDRESSED IT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
RAISED. THE THRESHOLD FOR THE
AMOUNT OF COPIES IN A PROJECT
FROM FIFTY CUBIC YARDS TO FIVE
HUNDRED- WHICH IS ONE OF HIS
REQUEST IN HIS LETTER SO I
THINK WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
ALREADY. AND WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
HIM AND WE FEEL THAT THEIR
INPUT IS IN GOOD FAITH AND- WE
MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH ALL OF IT
BUT WILL LISTEN ALL OF IT. AND
WILL HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE AN NINE MISTER BOND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES AT THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
INDUSTRY AGAIN FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT FOR BEING HERE
TODAY- I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP TO HELP US-
COULD YOU TO MOVE TOWARD OUR
GOALS OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE%
GAS EMISSIONS AND HAVING A
HEALTHIER PLANET AND RESPECT
THE ATMOSPHERE. OF VOTE ON A.
B. NINE SIXTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA BOUNCER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM THREE EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY SIX BY MEMBER BONTA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
FLORA FLORA NO CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA HI Là M<c.cyan>. I MATHIS</c>
NO. MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ NOT VOTING
RIGHT TO CHOOSE READ THROUGH GI
STONE STONE I. EIGHT TWO. BUILD
UP YOU TOO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU STAFF. I WILL LET THE
CALL IN A FEW BILLS AND GET
THAT WHAT MEMBERS OUT ON. ITEM
ONE A. B. NINETEEN BY WALDRON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT EIGHT TO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I ELEVEN ZERO. BILLS ELEVEN
ZERO. ITEM TWO AB FOR SIXTY
FOUR CRISTINA GARCIA DO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHAU AYE
MURATSUCHI. ROUTE TO GI ELEVEN
ZERO. I DON'T FOR A BI TEN
SEVENTY ONE LOW MOAN DO PASSED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS WITH
CONSENT RECOMMENDATION CURRENT
VOTE TENDED ZERO ABSENT MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. HI ROUTE TWO G. I
ELEVEN ZERO. ITEM FIVE AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE LEVINE TO
PASS IT'S AMANDA REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO TWO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. TRIAL I. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
NO RIGHT TO CHEAT MURATSUCHI
AYE NINE THREE. SO. EIGHT THREE
ZERO. YEAH EIGHT THREE I CAN DO
THE MATH THE THREE. ITEM SIX AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX BY MEMBER
MCCARTY. MOTION THAT THE
URGENCY BE ADOPTED AMENDING TO
PASS CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBER MARTUCCI
MURATSUCHI I ELEVEN ZERO. ITEM
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
ARTWORK HURRY TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT EIGHT TO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. OUR AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I ELEVEN ZERO. GOOD ALL RIGHT
NOT RESOURCES DURING